ce matin on se déplace on va les
rencontrer une dame de 76 ans nous voici
à bord de la voiture patrouille des
agents sociaux communautaires du SPVM
Julie Mazerolles du poste de quartier 42
à Saint-Léonard et Teri coco du poste de
quartier 30 à Saint-Michel visiblement
avec son discours et l'imagine des gens
qui sont souvent assis sur son divan
c'est pas la première fois que les
policiers avaient à faire à cette madame
là ce sont des placés chez elle ils ont
vérifié le logement où ils ont constaté
qu'il y avait personne cette visite se
fait dans le cadre du projet équinoxe
qui a pris son envol dans la dernière
année il vise à humaniser l'approche
policière afin d'éviter de judiciariser
des personnes qui ont besoin de soins en
santé mentale plutôt que des menottes
aux poignet
équinoxe c'est l'abréviation du
partenariat entre le SPVM et une équipe
médicale du sinus de l'Est
il y a eu des moments vous avez vécu
comme vraiment des épisodes de grandes
grandes grandes marques noires si vous
étiez très angoissé
j'ai envie encore chaque rencontre
permet donc de bâtir un lien de
confiance pour établir un profil par un
professionnel de la santé afin qu'il
puisse procéder à une évaluation j'ai
fait deux années de formation de poste
doctorales à Londres et c'est là
vraiment je me suis un peu initié à la
psychiatrie communautaire en Angleterre
sont vraiment très avancés là dans ce
qui réussissent à déployer vraiment dans
les différents quartiers de Londres en
considérant que près de 7 appels
d'urgence sur 10 implique une
intervention policière liée à la santé
mentale à Montréal l'implantation du
modèle de Londres par le docteur
bénédictis a permis d'offrir un
encadrement professionnel après de 100
personnes vulnérables en quelques mois
seulement ça m'amène beaucoup de
valorisation c'est qu'au niveau
professionnel mais je suis capable
d'aider à faire réduire les appels on a
fait je suis capable de travailler en
résolution de problème
les deux policières sont donc
conscientes que les relations étaient
personnelles font partie de leur travail
par la suite quand je les revois et que
je vois que ça va mieux que ça l'a amené
une qualité de vie alors quotidien mais
ça ça me rend heureuse pour eux déjà
d'autres corps de police au Québec ont
exprimé de l'intérêt pour le projet
équidox afin de l'implanter dans leur
municipalité ici Pascal Robida
Radio-Canada Montréal